all right here's the first story we got  this from timcast.com Biden wanted OPEC  OPEC plus Cuts delayed until after the  midterms Saudi Arabia says Biden now  faces allegations of quid pro quo  similar to alleged deal that was the  basis for impeaching former president  Donald Trump  the uh this is from Hans monk he says  this is extremely damning in Trump's  case the quote victim of the quid pro  quo zolenski emphatically denied there  was any suggestion of quid pro quo in  Biden's case the victim is formally  accusing the U.S of just that quick and  simple just to the story  Biden Administration goes to Saudi  Arabia and says we know you're going to  start cutting the production of oil  wait one month  just one month  that's uh uh conveniently just after the  midterms  Saudi Arabia said no we're not going to  do that and it's we're not going to do  it for economic reason